uh because california just loves paying
high gas prices let's give him a little
shout out here with what happened with
gas prices okay
california's will pay highest liberty
weekend gas prices ever fox business
story drivers in california will pay
more than labor day weekend for gasoline
than they have ever in the past for the
first time of year according to numbers
from automobile club of california the
current 439
4.39
per gallon price of regular gases
california's new record high for labor
day weekend up from 323 a year ago the
current national ave average is 3 18
and california is 439. the prior highs
per regular on liberty weekend was in
2012 when it was 416. the average price
of gas in u.s has continued to climb
since the beginning of last year in
deadly hurricane ida hitting the
critical refinery areas of the gulf
coast in recent days sparked concerns
that shortages could drive gas prices
even higher fy the record-breaking day
for california ever for gas prices was
october of 2012 four dollars and 70
cents what are your thoughts on gas
prices in california adam i'll go to you
first
well
by the way how do you remember that it
was october of 20th i looked at it yeah
i looked at it okay i don't know where
you were living in california october
2012 i'm in california look i think
it's sort of a combination of a few
things it's sort of the perfect storm
not to use the the ida
uh analogy there but
obviously the the hurricane hitting um
the refineries doesn't help
i think notoriously
the end of summer
labor day this is your last vacation
people are trying to hit the streets
people are trying to get out of there
supply
supply and demand people clearly want to
go hit the road and then obviously
you've got to look at inflation and say
all right like
is this here is this gonna is this
leaving i think it's just sort of the
perfect storm
and the the beautiful thing like in
capitalism you have a choice you don't
have to take that cross-country trip you
can stay home obviously a lot of people
in california thank you caroline
don't have to necessarily leave their
houses but
that's the beautiful thing if you don't
want to deal with these ridiculous
prices don't take a long road trip if
paying a buck or two extra
i mean what is that going to come out to
another 50 100 bucks on your trip is
really something you're not worried
about take your trip but obviously
nobody loves paying high prices for gas
but supply and demand it is what it is
but you live in california right you
lived in california i lived in
california we're used to these
ridiculous prices no well yeah they
always seem to go up around holidays
like labor day
fourth of july anytime that people are
traveling a bunch
but uh you know the thing with
california is
uh everything is so high the cost of
living is so high um that i think their
their economy is like could be the third
you know largest country in the world
just based out of california and what's
how much money goes through there and uh
and the country is just going to go in
the toilet
i mean there's so much homelessness
and they continue
again it's like
everything doesn't have to be political
but when you continue to elect the
people that are pushing for and allowing
things like uh you know the woman that
got shot and killed by the illegal oh
well he's not guilty and but people can
go in now and they can rob less than a
thousand dollars from a store and
literally just walk out of the store and
the cops aren't gonna get get called on
them uh and you can take a crap on the
street that's okay too but don't you
dare use a plastic straw
and then you look at how the state's
been ran by gavin nussolini
who's had absolute lockdown right on
businesses when uh all throughout the
whole entire state you've got people
that aren't working people that uh can't
go to work families that own businesses
that can't open their doors um
and then you wanna add high gas prices
on top of it so the perfect storm to me
is is uh not only what is taking place
with the gas line with hurricane ida all
that stuff does does play a part but for
california as a whole they need new
leadership over there you know they need
somebody that's actually going to say
okay wait a minute we need to make some
changes in how we're going to enact
these policies
we need to start focus on things that
are going to actually help californians
and the main thing that's going to help
california's is allowing them to go to
work allow them to open up their
businesses
if you you know california's probably
the closest state in new york is the
closest state to what we're seeing take
place in australia right now where i
post on my instagram on my way in here
today they're literally talking about a
system and
implementing a system in australia where
you can't go and buy or sell anything
unless you've gotten the jab they're
he's literally talking about they want a
vaccinated society in australia he's
like we're not there yet because we
still have people that you know we still
have open dates for you can get jet you
can get the jab uh but if you want to
get this vaccine you're gonna have to
get it because we're going to shut it
down it's like that's happening do you
think there's some dark forces at work
that are purposely driving up the gas
prices so californians aren't running
around town and doing that or is it just
actually because it's labor day
ida is there is there a hidden backstory
or is it because it is what it is with
supplying what i just i think i think it
is what it is i'm not sure you know i
mean
we're in a spiritual battle all the time
but you're not an action spiritual guy
yeah he's never been a conspiracy guy
what are you starting a conspiracy here
you're sitting
got to be careful with this guys there's
the lady i like that that's a good maybe
caroline put something else in there but
please go ahead so
so they just they need to do leadership
you know hopefully they'll get it
hopefully they'll actually get a fair
election uh on this recall with uh do
you think he's got a chance
i think larry older has a chance yeah if
the if the election is actually uh
credible i mean did you read that
article by l.a times about larry elder
what yeah the one calling him a racist
white supremacist white supremacist yeah
yeah
there's an article calling him
a white supremacist that's when you know
you're a threat is that an article from
the onion no no no no okay you know what
they did first pull up the price you
know what they did you know what this
reminds me of you just took trump's name
off of it but larry in there click on
regular yeah you've seen the chappelle
skit with the clayton bigsby
where he's the kkk
he's a black klansman yeah he was blind
he didn't know it's like what that's
what they're trying to pull on larry el
dorado to the right of alaska you see
where it says go to alaska no right
there on the list gas prices bottom
bottom kai bottom oh my gosh
the column
on this and it's going to do ranking by
the highest holy moly okay get that a
little higher
look this this is the biggest concern
though if you think about it i
understand if gas prices between a heist
and a bottom one is 30 cents maybe even
45 cents california is officially higher
than hawaii how the hell is gas prices
in california higher than hawaii
so california is 439 okay
premium you're paying 471 by the way
diesel's 438
then that go and that's average in the
state that's average in the state that's
some be some parts of the some parts of
the state are seeing five and six
dollars in gas that's right isn't
california more than anyone pushing
electric vehicles is this part part of
it well of course yeah they are and
we'll talk about the chip shortage but
so california you got 439 then you got
hawaii and nevada washington utah idaho
oregon alaska 366 wyoming illinois 333
montana new york new york is 320. how
the hell is new york 328 in california
is
439. how is that even these are both ran
by similar type of politics how the hell
is california a dollar a dollar higher
than new york and new york just got hit
with ida and new york is the one that
got hit without california
is 320. keep going lower arizona's 314.
north dakota's 360 adam if you're
thinking about it north dakota may not
be a bad movie lovely for you keep going
up keep going up ohio 3 28 florida three
three dollars at a penny okay
uh iowa's the first one that breaks the
two dollar mark keep going lower
keep going lower tennessee 290
texas is going to be the second to the
bottom i think yeah texas 280
mississippi 279. that's why you're in
texas so break this all down what do you
think is happening well first of all
states have
the ability to add their own individual
taxes which is what newsome did like tax
newsome added an additional gas tax 25
cents 15 cents 13 cents suck it's not a
big deal no one's going to pay and no
one's going to notice it it's just a 25
cent hike so california has some of the
most gas tax on top of everybody else
that they add to you're saying
california is kind of gassy
it is kind of gassy only you would think
of it but that's great that's our friend
who called you out well this is what
happens when you spend a lot of time
with kids last night you know there was
a lot of kids you're getting them to
dress up a little bit that was not me
first of all then you bring them up and
that was not me you don't pin that on me
that's don't you pin this on here
on you for the rest of your life oh i
went and adam said
dylan said adam asked me to dress up to
come to you
and i said adam's gonna be in trouble
for this one anyways so the biggest
conversation with this
again dude i don't mind if gas if you
tell me
you're in
alaska and you say look you're in hawaii
we don't have access to gas it has to go
from here to here to here to here to
here fine little bit of argument you're
california you're not new york you're a
buck higher than new york you're buck 10
higher than dc what is your argument
california keeps constantly hurting
themselves if there's ever been a time
for the state of california to be
willing to try another way of thinking
and leading like an elder or anybody
else this may be the time to do it and
by the way this guy actually stands a
chance and why not make history
first black governor of california ever
well l.a times would say first black
white
supremacist governor can you pull up
that uh article about uh it's disgusting
you know it is disgusting no question
about it they're using this playbook
like that's the hard part but but i got
it hopefully that's waking people up too
no to see that wait a minute you're now
calling a black guy that's been in
california most of his life on the radio
for 30 years trying to wake people up
you're now calling him a white
supremacist kyle you see the first one
like i don't understand what you're
doing you just click on it says white
supremacy go to the next one
kyle listen kai's defense he woke up he
was breakfast he woke up late today he's
david i'm sorry
which seats with kai today kai is kai
everything okay you work too hard at the
vault like what was he dead he did look
okay
l.a time story larry larry elders fans
prove he's a face of white supremacy
l.a times okay
you think somebody's gotta buy la times
maybe to just kind of uh shift their way
of thinking a little bit anyway so
california
just as two
you know black men
how do you register that a black man
being the face of white supremacy in
california how do you process this
ignorance and bigotry thank you
it's like they're you know it's it's the
bigot it's the racist that is gonna
throw out the race card as somebody
that's that a has nothing whatsoever to
do with the entire
mantra the entire phrase the ideology of
what a white supremacist is
um and and b is uh
just you know just doesn't care what
people think it's like they're
publishing this of national paper right
the la times publishing a story to their
to their readers tells you that they
believe that they've got enough of a
stranglehold programming right like tv's
programming enough of a programming
mechanism on their readers to believe so
well some of them won't believe it let's
just go ahead and run with it and the
other thing it does it completely
dilutes what it would mean to be a white
supremacist it's like they they want to
take the worst possible thing it's like
calling somebody hitler you know saying
they're they're they're nazi uh they
want to take the worst possible thing
and label somebody that to hope that
there's a shock reaction do you think do
you think that unfortunately
unfortunately it does for some folks
because they're so programmed they don't
know any difference you know you know
what i think that does though let me
tell you what this is my opinion i may
be completely and then i think some
people wake them up but go ahead yeah i
think i think to me
like
you you ever had somebody that was older
than you or whatever they tried to kind
of uh uh uh
impose a certain mindset on you to
divide you against a relative or
somebody that you knew well you know
that person yeah and they try to say
something that's the thing you knew him
well
right but what i'm saying is even if
somebody tries to patronize me
and i'm somebody that questions
everything that article pisses me off
even if i don't follow politics an
article like that gets me to say what
the hell are you talking about how many
are free thinkers at this point i think
more than you think because i think by
the way it's not the majority that's for
sure but i do think that 10 20 is more
than you think and it doesn't take look
at the end of the day how many people
does it take to change the generational
curse of any family how many how many
one person right it doesn't take fifty
not a hundred so if your family's filled
with alcoholics one guy says boom i'm
done i'm not doing it anymore we're not
alcoholics in this family well your dad
drank your grandfather drank your
uncle's drink i'm not doing it cocaine
drugs alcohol whatever it is somebody
eventually says what i'm you're poor
you're broke this entire family
everybody says we're poor we're poor
we're poor one person says done and then
all the other kids or nephews nieces
says one day i want to be like that
uncle one day i want to be like that
auntie one day i want to be like that
person it takes one person articles like
that i believe wakes up people who were
never involved in the first place and
then they say dude you know what i'm
getting the freaking ring what the hell
are you talking about yeah and then they
get pissed off that's what i bet on
that's what i hope happens more than
anything i think there's more free
thinkers than we think so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye
[Music]